benjamin lui l'a fait une partie de
poker ce week end
ouais tu es le roi du poker d'ailleurs
on sera poker un jour avec plaisir ça
fait dix ans que j'ai pas joué mais bon
si vous voulez c'est les appels depuis
dix ans alors et il a gagné
non je fais kit turbo quoi qui fait
quitter veut dire qu'il a perdu
j'imagine en moi j'ai vu qu'ils avaient
faits qui t'a fait deux fois que vous me
dites que vous avez fait piéger ces kits
d'allaiter qui tu kiffes équipe et donc
ça veut dire vous n'avez rien gagné on
est rien perdre voilà exactement
effective d'accord c'est un peu
l'histoire de votre vie mais c'est vrai
il a rien gagné n'a rien perdu
samar est revient aux benjamins on va
jouer avec le poids des chroniqueurs
[Rires]
benjamin revient à benjamin jean michel
maxi vous avez fait ce qu'elle blonde
est pas mal il ma fille cinéma j'étais
grand guan premier à recevoir ce que je
vois de ma vie mais je vaux mais cela
soit ce soir le premier quoi star wars
[Applaudissements]
il a joué au poker ce week end
oui est ce qu'il a fait j'ai gagné à la
max c'est bon il m'arrivait un truc tout
à l'heure j'étais tranquillement en
train de déjeuner il ya une femme
magnifique qui vient me voir je vois une
femme arrivée vers moi alors je me dis
elle a dû se tromper et en fait à la
rive comme salles arrive elle arrive
vers moi la rivière mois l'arrivée
rebonds et là me dit bonjour fibre jour
elle me dit je suis la mère de géraldine
maillet non m
une élégance une beauté eh bien
figurez-vous depuis sachez qu'on a passé
toute l'après midi ensemble c'est parce
qu'elle m'a dit bah écoute et a appelé
la chambre 304 mercure bo3 merci d'être
avec nous comment ça va contre ans c'est
vrai qu'on trouvera alors poteau et où
toi sentimental moi merci contre
toulouse après tout votre en vue de
l'appel de l'an lens
oui en picardie bah je connais un petit
peu je suis pas plus cons que j'en ai
l'air il ya le stade félix bollaert à
ils l'ont bien la honte à talons hauts
elle non oui parlons excuse moi je suis
un connard la petite chenille et aux
nazis tu peux toucher c'est beau ça
c'est château d'ax ses châteaux la
presse j'ai découpé sur un canapé
sud-ouest tu peux y aller bébé tué moi
qu'un téléphone filaire
le ghana est le tout n'est pas nouvelle
oui clara commence à ma chérie ouais tu
sais quoi nuit tombe à tous avec toi tu
es plus réveillé goutrens
[Applaudissements]
clara est ce que tu as envie d'aller en
grèce avec gautrand il est mignon contre
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas moi j'aime bien les
contraintes c'est son vrai prénom
ah oui clara j'ai reconnu ta droite
essaie d'imiter gontran bon on va jouer
avec vous la série à a aisément quand
même